oh
hi
hi i'm mars 23 i'm from new york you
guys all are beautiful by the way
[Music]
so if you would swipe right on mars
you're gonna stay
if you would swipe left as if no
exit the stage come take a sleep now
that's the nicest thing that's ever
happened
hey
how you doing i'm good how are you
nervous
a little bit not news to the attention
not really
are you a drinker i like departing
sometimes i travel a lot i do uh
modeling they take me places so i'm here
to do some shoots that's awesome do you
have like a model face that you do
i'll be honest i do not there isn't one
most of it is just like you're talking
and then there's take pictures while
you're doing stuff like a natural style
do they make you model shirtless
is when you audition for stuff most of
the time you can have a show can we get
a preview yeah
let me get a preview listen i got you
guys later okay don't worry about it so
being a model like do you date a lot or
like no your track record travel too
much even though i would love to have a
girlfriend though is she in this room
uh
i've had three girlfriends in my life
all of them have been long-ish term so
like two years yeah what's your zodiac
sign i'm a libra what does that mean
they said they were really nice they
also say we're indecisive it's also kind
of true well we're going to decide for
you yeah that's literally perfect you
know that's why it works for today yeah
i don't have to decide anything for real
so is there anything you're looking for
in particular like describe your type
okay not to be cliche physically i don't
really have a type but that's flying i
swear i promise you
there's three things i look for
hair
lips
and eyes okay classic body parts but
it's like everyone has those so it's
like yeah
yeah
i do tattoos though would you let me
tattoo you would you let me i totally
would my name starts with an e would you
let me tattoo
an e on it where would you put it
what's your controversial opinion
oh hi take i think that
people hype someday up too much
that is awesome
now she's great she's phenomenal people
put her on such a high pass i'm like
she's do you not think she's attractive
no she's cute okay okay what do you
think is your biggest red flag oh yeah
oh wow okay it's when someone's rude to
waiters and waitresses
super turn off yeah but i kind of want
to know what everyone's red flag is go
ahead go ahead lying for no reason
having a big ego like if you're always
right there's something wrong
liars bad at communication i don't like
controlling not like owning up their
mistakes definitely commitment issues
kind of like ego wait what's your ideal
type personality wise i do like to have
fun i like to be the quiet half like you
like to be there but not being too like
i like to be yeah i like to be like mix
adjacent well i feel like we need to
decide if our ideal type of lines with
his oh i was gonna say
what's your love language
i
like physical touch i noticed that
because there's a lot of people who i
don't want to touch me and so if i want
to touch me it's like oh yeah acts of
service i do like when it seems like
someone's thinking about you and so they
do something just thoughtful
that's
really nice
okay so does anybody want to be like
want to stay like
i'm having something
i think i think i'm still in the vibe
with martin so who like absolutely does
not want to stay
just right to it
okay
i like someone who's a bit more outgoing
yeah and i think i kind of want the guy
to lead like the
all the whole like yeah atmosphere and
all that do you guys feel like he's
funny
no no no
if he was funny he would have made his
life in that time you're right
i'm just saying i feel like he's
probably just shy maybe probably though
yeah it's pretty intimidating i mean i
appreciate how he said he's adventurous
yeah oh that is i think
he travels
are we allowed to vote ourselves
[Music]
so the girls eliminated this round are
kristen and kathy
[Music]
i'm sorry
[Applause]
i'm skipping away
[Music]
kennedy nice to meet you nice to meet
you i'm not gonna lie i'm a little i'm a
little shy i'm i'm a little shy too you
probably can't tell
the first thing i know about you is i
like your outfit oh thank you i chose it
because it was a bit of a power move you
play guitar yeah i play piano more
though piano is hard it is so you're
good with your hands i would say so okay
that's cool that's cool do you like to
travel i do love to travel when you said
you're adventurous that's like something
i really look for in a person you know i
was thinking about it before when you
said tattooing your e you would be down
yeah it would have to be on my face like
right here i don't know i just feel like
for it to really be meaningful yeah it
would have to be on my face oh yeah cool
i feel like that shows you're a
committed person should i get like a
mars
yeah get a planet on my face as well
nice get right there what's your thing
that's like really embarrassing for you
for me i don't like falling in public
you know it's gonna sound kind of weird
i don't really get embarrassed oh wow
like if i were to fall i would just
laugh at myself but like
eat [ __ ] like
yeah even so i'd just be like what's
your ring it is a
chroma hearts ring can i try it on
okay yeah you have a big finger yeah
these are
kind of thick not gonna lie do you like
to work out see that's a that's an
interesting question do i like to work
out or do you have to work out i have to
but at this point it's kind of like a
habit i do like feeling sore though
if that you know
so how'd you get your name did you like
make it up yourself mars
do you think i did
i think your friends did okay i'm
actually not going to tell you why
because it's a good secret now i have
something something to talk about i'm
from atlanta i go to morehouse no way
are you kidding do you like it it's cool
better than like new york
oh no no no no new york is the best city
on earth la is a close second that's an
opinion yeah it is an opinion but it's
the smaller one i have i'm really into
like fashion i got this from the flea
market it's nice but i do like fashion
it's the first thing you see so i feel
like you can tell a lot about their
personality
what can you tell about my personality
oh god you seem like you're fun and what
gives you that impression i don't know i
really don't know
it's like the whole thing what are your
biggest fears i would probably say being
alone yeah it's weird though because i'm
kind of sort of a homebody but i'm also
really not
but i'd rather be a homebody not by
myself
completely get you like i like like
watching netflix and like chilling but
with a boot would be great that's
literally telling you oh
nice to meet you nice to meet you
again
i think jasmine is his bae for real for
real did he immediately ask you
questions you sat down and he was like
so he had him ready for you i think that
he got along with you too like you were
making him nervous but also like elantra
yeah you guys have like really good
going like with a flea market and all
that stuff
[Music]
[Music]
i'm ready do you feel like they
made you made a good choice are you
nervous
a little bit i feel like the choice must
have been good to be honest one
two
three
jasmine oh what was that
how are you i'm good how are you doing
did you
expect me did i expect you
low-key
low-key low-key did you
expect to be here it was nervous but
maybe the suit did something all right
i'm gonna hand you this oh that's
hilarious and i'm gonna have you reveal
who you
are
[Music]
wow
round two i had
jasmine
ellen and
oh [ __ ]
for the last one
i have
[Applause]
i thought you didn't like i thought you
didn't pick me so i was like
are you gonna tell me what your name
means now oh oh yeah
on our on a date i got you yeah
i'll tell you about it
yeah
we're happy
[Music]